John: Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday, in
a stunning turn of events, I have found myself
in an airport.
I'm here because I'm on my way to Brazil to
attend the Paper Towns premiere there, and
actually, I won't be returning home to my
beloved Indianapolis International Airport
for 28 days, except for a brief sojourn thanks
to the love and support of Nerdfighteria,
but more on that in a moment.
Alright, Hank, I have a bunch of news.
First, bad news, my daughter Alice is a little
bit sick.
She threw up this morning and it was just
horrible to watch, because in addition to
like, the regular miseries of throwing up,
children can't understand what's happening
to them, so she was just like, wait, why is
something coming out of my mouth, my mouth
is for putting things in!
But she doesn't have a very good vocabulary,
so she just kept saying 'noooo'.
Oh, it was heartbreaking.
Okay, Hank, on to some slightly better news.
Cara Delevingne, Nat Wolff, Halston Sage,
and I are going on a brief tour of the United
States before the Paper Towns movie comes
out.
Basically, everyone could vote for their state
on Tumblr, and the winning states were Ohio,
Texas, and my own home state of Indiana.
Hank, it is not lost on me that Indiana is
a relatively small state that received a lot
of votes from kind people who do not live
here, but just thought that I might enjoy
having a day with my family, so thank you,
thank you, thank you.
So, Hank, we'll be in Indianapolis July 14th,
Columbus, Ohio July 15th, and Dallas, Texas
July 16th, all the events are free, they will
be crazy fun, lots of surprises, I don't know
the venues and the times yet, but I should
sometime in the next week, I will let you
know.
In even more good news, last night, Sarah
and a bunch of my friends saw the Paper Towns
movie for the first time, and they all really
liked it, or else they're lying, but no, I
do think they really liked it.
They laughed, they felt things, it was good.
But in terrible news, literally none of them
noticed my cameo in the movie.
I mean, Hank, at the end of the movie, my
life partner of more than a decade turned
to me and said, "That was such a great movie.
I thought you said that you were in it.
Where were you?"
So, yeah, Hank, I am in the movie, but apparently,
in a way that no one will notice.
Okay, even more good news.
Hank, the night before the Paper Towns movie
actually comes out in the United States on
July 24th, there will be a special event at
a couple hundred theaters on the night of
July 23rd.
That night of July 23rd is gonna be like the
first real public showing of the movie in
the US, and I'm so excited about it, and then
afterwards, there's gonna be this, like, livestream
beamed into theaters around the country featuring
the whole cast and also special guests I'm
not allowed to name.
I'm just really excited to celebrate the movie
with the whole cast and with the people who
care the most about the story, so yeah, we're
gonna answer your questions and sing songs,
it's gonna be tons of fun, nightonthetowns.com,
there's a link in the doobly-doo.
Alright, Hank, now to the news that for many
years, I thought would be bad, but I think
actually might turn out to be kind of great.
So Hank, more than 10 years ago, I sold the
movie rights to my first novel, Looking for
Alaska, and as you know, since then, I have
frequently tried to get them back.
Hank, there's a big part of me that never
wanted a Looking for Alaska movie to be made.
The story is very personal to me, I know it
matters a lot to a lot of its readers, but
then again, the money we made from selling
the movie rights was extremely important to
us, it allowed us to move to New York so Sarah
could go to graduate school and pursue her
dream of becoming a curator.
So I could never really regret it, but as
you know, Hank, over the years, it's been
difficult for me, I've had some mixed feelings
about it.
But Hank, suddenly it seems like the movie
isn't just going to happen, it's going to
happen in a way that I can be really proud
of.
Weber and Neustadter, who also wrote the screenplays
for The Fault in Our Stars and Paper Towns
have written a beautiful script and Becca
Thomas who previously directed the movie Electric
Children has just been hired to direct Looking
for Alaska, and that means that it's probably
gonna happen.
It might still fall apart, things often do,
but now I hope that it doesn't, because I
really like Becca and she gets the book all
the way down.
So yeah, I am excited about the prospect of
a Looking for Alaska movie are words I never
thought I would say, but I am.
I hope you guys are excited too, and I hope
you're excited for the Paper Towns movie,
I know that it's scary when a book is turned
into a movie, I mean, it's very scary for
me, but it's exciting, too, so Hank, that's
the news.
Oh wait, a couple more pieces of good news.
The United State Supreme Court did not cancel
our health insurance, Hank, and also, no matter
who you are, and no matter where you live
in the United States, you can marry the person
you love.
Here's to the activists and decades of activism
that made that happen.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.
p.s.
Hank, I tried to bring a champagne popper
into the airport so I could have a big huzzah
at the end of the video, but it turns out
that's not allowed.